sowas von die club bleibt ein kleiner
hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video bereits im gestrigen video
angekündigt wollte ich in dem heutigen
video mal so ein bisschen über diese
killer klauen medien hochgepusht sache
ein video machen und darüber erzählen
weil es ja doch derzeit überall
irgendwie gesprächsthema ist dass da
irgendwelche leute sich als clowns
verkleidet und alle leute in angst und
schrecken versetzen wollte eigentlich es
kein video zu dem thema machen weil ich
dachte das ist irgendwie so einheit das
wird von den medien ihnen die hoch
gepusht aber irgendwie nimmt es jedoch
derzeit überhand und lebt mittlerweile
auch so in die kriminelle richtung wir
hatten eine freundin letzten sonst net
geschickt in dem sie seinen killer clown
in leipzig fotografiert hatte man dann
so dass da viele clowns unterwegs sind
dann habe ich eine facebook gruppe
gesehen die glaube ich irgendwie so
heißt killer clowns mit scheiße bewerfen
oder habe ich vor ein paar tagen auch
dass sie in den nachrichten gelesen ein
täter in einem clownskostüm und einen
19-jährigen in rostock bierhoff
angegriffen und mit einem
baseballschläger verletzt die polizei in
der nacht zum freitag mitteilte schubste
der unbekannte den mann bei der tat am
donnerstag steam zu boden und bedrohte
ihn auch ein 15 jähriger wurde am selben
tag in rostock von einem grusel clown
bedroht der verkleidete sei mit einem
messer in der hand auf den jugendlichen
zugelaufen daraufhin flüchtete der 15
jährige unverletzt an die clowns seid
ihr penis geballter ohne spaß was seid
ihr für ausgeburten der hölle alter was
fällt euch ein band täter in einem
clownskostüm hat einen 19-jährigen in
rostock wird oft angegriffen und mit
einem baseballschläger verletzt wenn ich
dich sehen würde würde ich dir sowas von
die club bleipreise kleiner
was bildet ihr euch ein aber weiter im
programm witzig findet die horror clowns
schon lange niemand mehr jetzt hat das
unheimliche phänomen das im august in
den usa seinen anfang genommen
ein erstes todesopfer gefordert in
kambodscha trat ein gebürtiger
amerikaner gruseln clownskostüm auf der
flucht vor aufgebrachten dorfbewohnern
auf eine landmine ich war halt nicht
dabei ich kann es nicht wirklich
beurteilen aber das was ich halt darüber
gelesen habe kann ich euch einmal ganz
kurz wieder geben es war quasi so da war
hielt ein student irgendwie so um die 20
rom und hat seine familie dort besuch
und hat glaube ich seine neffen
irgendwie so clownsmaske mitgebracht und
sich selber auch so guse clown kostümen
und hat dann sich da einen spaß erlaubt
einfach irgendwelche dorfbewohner mitten
in der nacht zu erschrecken ich will ihn
gar keine bösen absichten vorwerfen
allerdings muss er halt damit rechnen
wenn der sonne aktion durchführt das ist
böse konsequenzen haben kann dann haben
ihnen die dorfbewohner quasi die ganze
zeit so gejagt irgendwie ich stelle mir
das so vor wie bei simpsons mit den mist
gab hilfe sowie zählt dann über irgend
so eine grenze darüber gelaufen ist und
dort lagen hat enorm viele landminen und
die dorfbewohner wussten dass halt und
sind dann halt irgendwie da stehen
geblieben und erst hat weiter
weggelaufen irgendwie haben die alte
niebels lauten knall gehört und die mine
los gegangen ist und er wurde daher
komplett zerfetzt muss das video ist ab
18 freigegeben und das war der erste
todesfall ich weiß nicht ob es schon
todesfälle gibt wo wirklich ein killer
clown jemanden getötet hat aber ich
schwöre euch wenn ich lese dass ein
killer clown jemanden erschreckt hat und
ihn dann umgebracht hat ich sage ich
wenn ich einen killer clown auf der
straße sehen ich nehme meine so weit in
den usa schon alles aus
der senat verliert unser komplettes
verliert ich hasse euch hier sehr sehr
gute freundin von mir hat mega angst vor
clowns und das auch nicht erst seit ein
paar tagen sondern wirklich schon
eigentlich seitdem sie auf der welt ist
als kohl phobie wird die krankhafte
angst vor clowns bezeichnet einige
kinder haben angst vor clowns selten ist
diese angst auch bei erwachsenen
anzutreffen dies hat dann jedoch andere
gründe ich weiß nicht wie extreme meines
vertrauens sein muss um das coole phobie
zu nennen habe ich würde sagen dass
diese freunde von mir das schon
ja die hat schon eine coole phobie würde
ich sagen die kann sich halt den kleinen
raum setzen wo irgendwie ein
clownskostüm es und rastet aus wenn sie
so was irgendwie an karneval sieht oder
so also das ist schon krass und ich frag
mich einfach was passieren würde wenn
sie nachts vom training aus dem
fitnessstudio nach hause leute dann
kommt so ein spaß die im klaus kostümen
an und erschreckt sie ich glaube das
wird echt nicht gut enden und die hat
dann locker gegen den herzinfarkt oder
so aber wie kam es eigentlich zu diesem
scheiß killer clown trend der killer
klar und trennen kann zuerst in den usa
an sogenannten prank videos auf bereits
2014 entwickelte er sich in frankreich
zu einem ernsten problemen derzeit sind
es vor allem wieder die usa und
großbritannien die zahlreiche solcher
fälle melden neuester trend nicht im
netz kursieren zahlreiche keller clown
frank videos auf denen personen im
clownskostüm leute erschrecken oft
während sie ihren sprach ich am ende auf
und stellen das stolz videos davon ins
netz mit den halloween fest vor der tür
scheint eher trennen und auch in
deutschland hoch zu kochen es ist also
aufgekommen durch irgendwelche praise
und dann habe ich einfach mal bei
youtube danach geburt und die ersten
trainings liegt dazu gefunden habe waren
damit von dm prank ich habe glaube ich
keine rechte davon irgendetwas in diesem
video hierzu benutzten aber was sie dort
war sie gemacht haben war sich als
clowns verkleideten dann einfach zu
irgendwelchen leuten hingegangen sind
wirklich mit der kettensäge und diese
des todes erschreckt haben
was seid ihr für spaß dies ich hasse
solche menschen zuschauen meines kanal
feldern wissen dass ich selber schon mal
den ein oder anderen prank gemacht habe
und ich äußere mich ja auch immer
extremst gegen prey 2 licht frames
einfach komplett verabscheue aber meiner
ansicht nach gibt es zwei verschiedene
arten von trends nämlich einmal die
trends die man an freunde spielen die
irgendwie ein bisschen verarscht und die
brain ist man dann leute spielt die
eigentlich gar nicht richtig involviert
sind also quasi einfach irgendwelche
anonymen leute auf der straße sind und
diese trends an freunde finde ich mega
cool finde ich mega witzig wenn freunde
andere freunde verarschen so das macht
man ja jeder freundschaft über diese
prinz mit anonym leuten die da
eigentlich überhaupt nicht involviert so
gar keinen bock darauf haben leute die
solche projekte durchführen sind für
mich keine leute natürlich ist es witzig
anzuschauen und nicht jeder frank endet
irgendwie tödlich oder gefährlich oder
so was ich meine es gibt ja auch so
sachen um einfach niemandem wasser ins
gesicht spritzt oder so was habe ich
eigentlich hier oben schon wieder
sowieso eine peperoni um so auf den
punkt zu bringen alle frames wo die
leute an dem man einen franc ausübt
nicht wirklich in das ganze szenario mit
integriert sind verabscheue ich einfach
und vor allem wenn es um sowas geht die
leute erschrecken oder sobald ich bin
zum beispiel mensch ich bin enorm
schrecker und ich sage ich wenn mich
einer erschrecken würde auf der straße
ich würde nicht einfach sagen okay du
sagtest ein break das ist in horten
sondern er wird mich halt mega abfangen
und ich kann nicht garantieren dass ich
da nicht amtlich werde dann habe ich
halt vor einigen tagen auch das hier
gelesen wenn einer whatsapp nachricht
ich zurzeit ohne schülern in der region
verbreitet wird heißt das die polizei
hat darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass jeder
an halloween wegen dieser killer clowns
zu hause bleiben soll dafür eine
säuberung in dem film the page ausführen
wollen die nachricht ende bitte aussagen
dass die clowns eben jeden ermorden
wollen den sie sehen und stieß mit der
bitte diese information an alle freunde
weiter zu verbreiten ja ok normaler
mensch wird jetzt sagen alter spielt mal
the purchase irgendwie kennt diese pearc
geht es einfach darum dass in einer
nacht alle verbrechen erlaubt sind und
man quasi jeden umbringen kamen jede
straftat begehen kann aber dafür quasi
nicht vom gesetz heimgesucht wird und da
ist jetzt irgendwie sonne whatsapp
nachricht verbreitet worden dass das
diese killer clowns auch an halloween
durchführen wollen und leute umbringen
wollen also natürlich okay ich denke
auch mal das ist fähig und ich glaube
das hat ja auch schon als fake nach so
dass spam nachrichten pro aber so viele
leute haben darüber berichtet alter also
es ist nicht einfach nur irgend so ein
kleines ding diese clowns sache also was
will ich euch jetzt endlich mit diesem
video sagen an alle die das hier gerade
schauen und euch will ich eigentlich
nichts sagen also ihr seid ihr ganz
normales zuschauer hier und ich denke
nicht dass einer von euch so dumm ist
und sich als killer clown verkleidet auf
die straße geht aber an euch killer
clowns die das irgendwie machen und dies
wird sich finden leute zu erschrecken
dann irgendwie vielleicht eine
krankhafte angst vor clowns entwickeln
und sich nicht mehr nach draußen trauen
und weiß ich um uns allen irgendwie
alles kaputtmachen was seine söhne
ich habe letztens von kommentare
facebook gelesen unter seinen killer
staunen beitrag und da hat einfach
irgend so eine frau geschrieben ist doch
ganz klar dass die immer weiter machen
wenn ihr denen auch noch eine plattform
gibt wenn die keine aufmerksamkeit mehr
bekämen würde sich das schnell legen und
das ist quasi jetzt auch die aussage mit
der ich das video beendet man darf
diesen killer clowns keine
aufmerksamkeit geben ich habe youtube
kanäle gesehen die haben in 20 stunden
34 videos zu dieser clown sache
hochgeladen die bild passte täglich
darüber und ich sehe schon kommen dass
bei napoleon marschiert andere komische
prank youtuber da auch krank zu machen
werden solange dieses gehalte von diesem
keller clowns weitergeht hat das
wahrscheinlich nie ein ende als sich
selber rede jetzt auch überhaupt nicht
aus erfahrung gehabt so ein killer kaum
noch nie gesehen und wenn ich einen den
sollte heute gehen halt einfach aufs
maul aber es ist ganz simpel wenn einem
thema aufmerksamkeit gegeben wird dann
ist es auch noch weiter in den medien
und noch weiter in den köpfen vorhanden
was damit einfach sagen will beschäftigt
euch damit nicht so viel auch wenn das
jetzt gerade zum riesen thema ist
ich denke hier 99,9 prozent haben noch
keinen keller kollegen die auf den
straßen gesehen und wenn man einen sieg
kann man die auch glaube ich anzeigen
hat die polizei gesagt und geht an
halloween und am 11 bitte nicht als
clown verkleidet über die straßen weil
die polizei schon gesagt dass sie davon
ihren personalien aufnehmen werden und
ich glaube das wollen wir alle nicht
super luca einfach vergessen die and car
aufzunehmen ich wollte mir noch bei euch
bedanken fürs zuschauen
danke dass ihr euch das komplette video
gegeben habt und wenn ihr jetzt gerade
noch dran seid schreibt mal killer clown
in die kommentare
weil das video war bei mir glaube ich
nach oder teil gerade irgendwie 26 27
minuten lang und das zeigt mir halt
einfach dass ihr sowie über seit sich
das video bis zum ende gegeben haben was
das hier oben auf meiner stirn das weiß
ich immer noch nicht das war glaube ich
zu beginn des videos noch nicht da jetzt
ist es auf einmal da kann ich ran somit
mal von nein kann ich nicht super cool
gegen eine haut irritation ich keine
ahnung was ich auf jeden fall noch sagen
würde was mich interessieren würde wäre
das ihr mir auch mal die kommentare
schreibt ob ihr schon erfahrungen mit
killer clowns gemacht habt also wenn ihr
irgendeine story bis zur ja eine
freundin von mir setzt es daran gelaufen
durch sondern etwas dunklere gast und
kam so ein killer klar aus schreibt die
bitte einfach mal hier und in die
kommentare weil ich würde unglaublich
gerne wieder machen zu diesen ganzen
stories die idee dann schreibt dass wir
halt einfach mega cool und vielleicht
können wir da irgendetwas bewegen dass
diese spaß dies aufhören verkleidet als
clowns auf die straße zu gehen und leute
zu erschrecken weil ich sage euch selber
ich habe zwar keine krasse angst vor
clowns aber wenn ich so einen sehen
würde habe ich ja schon oft genug gesagt
ich weiß nicht wie ich ausraste führt
aber das war es jetzt auch vom video ihr
seht hier ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr mal ein kanal
abonnieren und ihr seht hier den block
aus amsterdam eingeblendet den ich vor
zwei tagen hochgeladen habe könnt ihr
euch einfach mal angucken ist ein
bisschen anderer blog und dann sehen wir
uns entweder an den videos oder im
nächsten video